luigi envie de ville au musée comme
magna comme tu fais un temps réfléchi a
peur on en est là oh bien je monte où
l'on va on va se planter ici non non on
va pas se planter sa tente d'aller des
mois ils parlent crocodile alors je vais
vous traduire qu'est ce que tu me dis
saint-augustin oui dans tedx vème siècle
bon je crois que tu t'es bourré la non
non non non saint-augustin a dit lors
d'un tedx ou 5ème siècle
si je me trompe c'est que j'existe a
donc si on se plante c'est qu'on existe
ah ben c'est formidable alors je suis
très heureux si heureux si je me plante
je serai encore plus heureux
là je suis très heureux d'être avec vous
parce que vous êtes des gens fabuleux et
je vais révéler quelque chose sur vous
que vous ne connaissez pas vous êtes des
gens merveilleux parce que vous êtes
curieux c'est pour ça que vous êtes
l'agent et vous savez d'où vient le mot
curieux curieux vient d'un mot latin qui
veut dire soigner la cure
si vous êtes là si vous voulez vous
soigner et si vous soigner vous êtes
bien et si vous êtes bien avec vous vous
serez bien avec les autres
vous êtes des gens formidables je vous
félicite et on va continuer à travailler
sur ce thème
by que you'll be généreuse by ap eu
d'accord vous êtes d'accord sur ce
programme
on y va allez on va avancer
on va avancer et je vais maintenant
m'être sérieux avec moi ça va être
difficile mais mon bonheur
je suis en début de carrière c'est que
je me mets pourquoi il y en a qui rigole
oui bonjour mon bonheur actuellement
c'est d'aider des jeunes à relever les
défis des prochaines années 50 pour cent
des jobs seront robotisée 50% de nos
enfants seront tous auto entrepreneurs
donc qu'est ce que je fais je vais avec
mon petit mon petit crocodile dans les
écoles primaires pour leur parler de
robotique mais pas qu'un mais pas que je
le redis coûté moi je viens bénévolement
pour vous parler de robotique
mais moi je vous demandais en échange
quelque chose qui va transformer votre
vie
voyez bien phû magicien vous allez
devenir extraordinairement heureux je
vais vous transformez alors les enfants
meurent grave qu'est ce que c'est bon et
d'écouté moi je vais vous demander
qu'une seule chose d'écouter la phrase
magique
il écoutait la phrase magique c'est
celle je ne parlerai jamais des autres
sauf pour en dire du bien
je ne parlerai jamais des autres sauf
pour en dire du bien
pour dire du bien et vous allez recopier
ça dans votre cahier vous allez le
mettre dans la classe et vous allez
l'appliquer si vous faites ça vous allez
gagner du respect de la confiance
vous aurez beaucoup d'amis et votre vie
sera très belle des enfants non
seulement ils ont appliqué ça mais ils
ont fait des dessins dans les dans les
classes des cms l2 des dessins pour
exprimer leur gratitude vis-à-vis de
leurs copains tu des dessins merveilleux
tu as beau sourire je t'aime tu es
gentil on voit même l'enfant qui
repêchent un enfant qui est tombé dans
l'eau et caetera et on les entraîne à la
gratitude à dire merci et après on leur
parle de robotique ça c'est pour les cm1
cm2 et la sixième et puis il ya certains
adultes peut-être qu'ils pourraient
également temps en temps écouter le
message
1 on a qu'à écouter la télévision pour
voir que cela pourrait le renvoyer
on pourrait le renvoyer ce message aussi
alors pour être heureux ne disons du
bien que d autres soyons bienveillant ne
jugeons ne soyons jamais dans le tube
pour les pour les auto entrepreneurs qui
sont qui ont une vingtaine d'années
j'interviens dans les universités le
message sont un petit peu plus complexe
mais je veux les aider à prendre
confiance en eux et les aider à faire
leur chemin de vie alors voilà ce que ce
que je propose c'est ccc la wii alors eu
dans un télex tedx qu'a eu lieu je crois
15e siècle c'est un des premiers textes
aussi de ja et race qui est intervenu
aussi un on a fait des recherches a su
sur l'antériorité du tedx et erasme est
venu et il a 17 francs sans médaille
pour vivre il faut trois choses
votre esprit votre corps et les biens
extérieur formidable il y avait tout
compris ce type là ça les hôteliers que
ce soit la prends comme chose en sort
bien on est beaucoup moins bête au début
qu'à la fin un débat que vous ne croyez
pas un grand décompte et que tout ce
qu'on a entendu alors j'ai repris rejas
merci et valls pour expliquer aux
enfants aux enfants aux jeunes
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un chemin de vie
alors je leur ai dit d'abord vous avez
un cerveau aux pandores je me trompe
vous avez un cerveau ce qui est nouveau
c'est qu'on en a trois on va y revenir
c'est peut-être la partie la plus la
plus intéressante de cette présentation
ensuite vous avez un corps à corps qui
bouge ensuite vous avez les autres et
puis tout ce à quoi ça sert ben ça sert
qu'à une seule chose c'est l'utilité
sociale ça cherche pas à avoir de
l'argent ni du pouvoir ni de la gloire
ni du succès la seule chose importante
quand vous fermez vos yeux sur votre
dernier livre de deux morts de vie parce
que c'est que c'est parce qu'on va la
vie la vie existe parce que la mort
existe y avait pas de morts il
n'existerait pas
c'est l'utilité sociale
si on peut si on peut pas être utile aux
autres ça ne sert à rien quand j'ai fait
le dessin j'ai vu une flèche pour dire
voilà il faut que ça monte là bas il
faut aligner les étoiles comme on dit
aligner des étoiles ça veut dire que
tout doit être cohérent la cohérence du
corps de l'esprit de rock des relations
avec les autres dans le but de faire de
l'utilité sociale appelée fait cette
flèche comme ça parce que moi je suis
dessinateur c'est beau c'est ma vraie
passion moi je suis magistrat dans un
temps on me dit que je suis ceci cela
mais ma vraie maman vrai bonheur c'est
faire des faire des images alors j'ai
fait c'est cette flèche pour monter
voilà ça doit monter comme ça et puis
une fois que j'ai fait cette fraîche je
suis dit mais attention cette flèche
c'est peut-être la transcendance
pourquoi pas la droite s'est compliquée
la transcendance père se comprendre mais
j'ai dit c'est peut-être quelque chose
qui qui traverse tout et je me suis dit
mais peut-être que la transcendance
c'est peut-être là mme pascale âme tout
le monde en parle là mais personne n'a
vu un début l'âme est quelqu'un qui a vu
l'arrêté
non y'a papa n'est pas vu là moi non
plus alors je me suis dit peut-être que
là mais là et puis il faut que j'ai
mille âmes j'ai dit mais attention l'âme
c'est peut-être l'amour dans le fond si
on est amoureux de soi mott's encore
hameau des autres à mon amoureux de
notre activité sociale peut-être que la
vie sera belle
alors amour et âme je sais pas alors
j'ai décidé d'écrire à meaux avec un
accent circonflexe sur le et je vous
laisse choisir vous-même d'accord voilà
alors on va continuer à travailler sur
le chemin de vie des jeunes ont commencé
par le troisième cerveau on a trois
cerveaux road vous a toujours dit que
vous avez un cerveau émotionnel et
fouras yeux irrationnel
on est tous d'accord là dessus ayad le
cerveau un mât c'est pas vrai
cana un troisième qui est un cerveau que
j'appelle le cerveau culturel où l'hymne
éthiques
c'est une découverte fabuleuse
été fait il ya une vingtaine d'années
quand on a découvert les neurones
miroirs et qu'on a découvert le mit
maîtrise et conect compris comment on
apprenait et le cerveau c'est incroyable
c'est 100 milliards deux cent milliards
de neurones et le nombre de connexions
est au carré de ce chiffre là dans votre
cerveau il ya toute l'histoire de
l'humanité
un jour retrouvera dans votre cerveau
des traces ce qui s'est passé il ya des
milliers et des milliers d'années il a
soixante dix mille ans votre cerveau et
tous les jours tous frais tout neuf
au moment où je vous parle je fais dans
votre cerveau jabril dans votre cerveau
des petits traits des petites lignes qui
voit un jour devenir des petites europe
qui vont devenir des petites rivières
qui vont devenir des fleuves parce que
petit à petit à partir de ce qu'on se
dit sur un sujet donné
vous allez enrichir ce petit torrent
parce qu'entre vous et nous entre vous
et moi se passe des ondes
on peut mesurer vin vous m'envoyer des
ondes
je vous envoie des ondes et ses hontes
imprime des choses dans votre cerveau et
vous vous me renvoyez les mêmes choses
et quand vous êtes ici 500 c'est moi le
grand bénéficiaire de cette opération
enfin pascal à sa soeur qui m'ont avoué
et ça a payé la déperdition en ligne
alors je remercie beaucoup le tedx 2
me nourrir mon cerveau parce que sinon
je serais db bon donc le cerveau c'est
quelque chose qui est extraordinaire et
ce qui fonctionne comme ça quand vous
m'avez arrive lui arriver les 20
premières millisecondes zaïdi retiens
c'est un vieux schnock tumeur et puis je
passerai votre cerveau rationnel a dit
bof 250 millisecondes après il a dû au
fait que si on l'a invité là peut-être
une ou deux choses à dire 1 et après 250
millisecondes après votre cerveau
culturelle s'est ouvert comme un livre
en dix d'entre eux tous ils avaient
peut-être podium ou de conneries qu'ils
sont peut-être bon à savoir 1 1
et alors ir souvent un phénomène de
feedback
c'est à dire que plus vous allez
apprendre quelque chose sur ce même
sujet et plus vous allez vous vous
enrichir on n'a pas le temps je me fais
engueuler parce que dépasse le temps
alors on va venir à l'intuition
l'intuition qu'est ce que c'est on parle
toujours d'un puissions mais qu'est ce
que c'est que l'intuition c'est quand à
partir d'une perception émotionnelle
nous allons directement culturel on n'a
pas le temps de discuter là dessus mais
ça c'est une décision qui vous fait
gagner 250 millisecondes et je vous
assure que quand vous êtes un pilote de
chasse et que le que le gars arrive avec
son truc vous devez éviter une voiture
parce qu'il ya une vache qui passe au
dessus de temps dans votre sur la route
c'est ça qui vous sauve la vie alors
l'intuition conserver là c'est un signe
de vie
d'accord
j'ai encore trois minutes il faut que
j'aille la métaphore technologique votre
cerveau travail commun comme un coq
comme un ordinateur les émotions
l'ordinateur est un clic on y connecte 0
et à l'oreille plus qu'aucun ordinateur
c'est pas possible ah oui ou non 0 1
par contre le disque dur c'est la
culture et c'est là bien les logiciels
et en plus maintenant il ya la wi fi
la meilleure façon de comprendre le
cerveau c'est un ordinateur vous n'avez
tout chez vous j'y vais parce qu'après
je veux pas passer le temps alors le
plus important de tous c'est maintenant
que j'y arrive
vous comprenez comment fonctionne le
cerveau maintenant il faut entraîner
votre cerveau il faut entraîner votre
cerveau il faut entraîner votre ferme et
ont fait de la façon la plus simple
possible
l'émotionnel c'est l'enfant qui est
angle ils sont le rationnel c'est
l'adulte et en nous qu'ils résolvent et
le culturel
c'est le parent est en nous qu'ils
jugent télé trois positions qu'on a
toujours dans la vie où on sent ou en
résonnent aux juges et à chaque fois
qu'on est devant dans un problème
d'ordre stop dans une situation je vais
vous donner un exemple vous avez les
trois possibilités ça c'est un défilé du
14 juillet l'enfant a trouvé que c'est
beau qui est de la musique que ceux-ci
qu'il ya il est ravi l'adulte lui va
dire est ce que vraiment au moment de la
cyberguerre tout ça est ce que les
chaussées vraiment très importante pour
se défendre a que soit passée vous 1 1
les chevaux actuellement c'est peut-être
parce qu'à dieu
bon mais les mêmes et même l e par heure
le parent qui est en nous dit mais quand
même c'est bien il faut montrer à la
télévision
l'idée de patrie que c'est important que
c'était symboles forts etc mais ils ont
tous les trois raisons il faut pas juger
faut savoir qu'on a toujours ses trois
idées dans la tête et la grandeur de
l'homme c'est d'avoir des idées opposées
dans la tête c'est ça qui nous fait
qu'on est grand et que la vie est belle
mais il faut toujours dire que ces
contradictions
c'est la source de notre richesse au va
j'ai encore une minute
la grandeur de l'homme c'est d'avoir des
idées opposées dans la tête et continuer
à fonctionner loi dit on va pas aller
plus loin
la dernière image que je vais vous
donner et c'est peut-être la plus forte
que je veux vous gardiez moi j'ai j'ai
beaucoup navigué toute ma vie j'ai
navigué prix et quand vous naviguez vrai
beaucoup de temps et je me suis aperçu
que la vie c'est une croisière
la vie c'est d'une croisière il faut
d'abord choisi au pardon il faut d'abord
choisir
il faut choisir un cap ils m'ont caps et
l'utilité sociale joue les jets votre
corps c'est la coque
tenez là en bonne forme parce que sinon
le bateau a coulé un là qui sait les
valeurs les valeurs profondes de justice
sociale de confiance de respect d'amour
sur lequel il faut jamais transigé
jamais plongée la voile c'est l'enfant
qui est en nous c'est ça qui vous fait
bouger c'est ça qui est le moteur de
votre de votre existence est celui qui
résonne chez l'adulte qui va à gauche à
droite il est dans la il est dans la
tactique il sait pas à gauche à droite
celle du mauvais vent etc et la vie ça
fonctionne comme ça on se fixe à 15 on
se base sur des valeurs qui sont pas
négociables
on experts on espère que le vent sera
favorable et ensuite la tactique de dire
ben oui ben jouer à gauche vers la
droite
et après ça si on applique ça le parole
juge l'adulte résonne l'enfant réagit et
vous serez tous heureux bic curieuse
by généreuse be nice